ALLAN WEINBERGER:
Welcome, Google.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you, guys.
Born in Chicago, Illinois,
Jay Chandrasekhar
is a director, actor, writer,
and comedian, best known
for his cult classics
"Super Troopers,"
"Club Dread," and "Beerfest."
He has also directed for
numerous popular TV shows,
including "Arrested
Development," "Community,"
"Chuck," "The Grinder,"
"New Girl," and "Psych."
Currently, he's on tour
promoting his new book
"Mustache Shenanigans,"
as well as
promoting his highly anticipated
release of "Super Troopers 2,"
set to launch later this year.
Please welcome me
in introducing Jay.
[APPLAUSE]
Welcome to Google.
JAY CHANDRASEKHAR:
Thank you very much.
ALLAN WEINBERGER: How are you?
So before the movies and before
your comedy troupe Broken
Lizard, you were actually born
and raised here in Chicago.
Did you grow up with
a comedic upbringing?
JAY CHANDRASEKHAR:
I mean, you know, I
grew up in the suburbs
of Chicago in Hinsdale.
And my friend's
brothers introduced us
to "Monty Python
and the Holy Grail"
and also introduced
us to The Beatles.
And so that was sort
of the beginning
of thinking about what a
comedy group was all about.
I remember listening to
the Steve Martin album
"Let's Get Small."
And then I saw the Richard
Pryor concert film "Live."
It's Richard Pryor live.
It's the one in Long Beach.
And that is I think the best
recorded stand-up that's
ever been put on film.
When I was 15, my dad took
me to the Chicago Theatre
to see Eddie Murphy in concert.
ALLAN WEINBERGER: Wow.
JAY CHANDRASEKHAR: It was the
"Delirious" tour, and it was--
we sat in the very back
row of the Chicago Theatre.
And I was like, that's a job?
I mean, wow.
So that's sort of the
beginnings for me.
ALLAN WEINBERGER:
And then you were
a traditional-- you went to
Colgate and started up comedy.
But when did you
say, like, you know
what, I'm going to really push
this comedy thing full-time?
JAY CHANDRASEKHAR:
Well, I was at Colgate
and I had been a writer and--
I'm sorry.
I had been an actor in
high school and college.
I had been in a lot of plays.
Am I supposed to
talk to them or you?
ALLAN WEINBERGER:
You know what--
to all of us, to everybody.
JAY CHANDRASEKHAR: OK.
ALLAN WEINBERGER: Sure.
To them.
JAY CHANDRASEKHAR: I've been
talking to you all afternoon.
ALLAN WEINBERGER:
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We've been together.
He did a Reddit
AMA earlier today
and I was able to
sit in on that.
I kind of felt like a
voyeur-- kind of weird--
but it was fun to
watch from that side.
JAY CHANDRASEKHAR: Thank you.
It was fun to have
you watching me.
ALLAN WEINBERGER: Yeah.
Thank you, Jay.
JAY CHANDRASEKHAR: I can't
remember the question.
Oh, yeah, I remember now.
I was a writer and--
shit, I wasn't a writer.
I was an actor in high
school and college.
And I was in a lot of plays,
like "Death of a Salesman."
I was Tony in "West Side Story."
You know, because
in the theater,
it's all race-blind casting.
But when I looked at
the movie screens,
I noticed that there
were no Indians on them
and there were no Indians in TV.
I mean, Ben Kingsley
had won for "Gandhi,"
but I didn't think they were
going to take a "Gandhi 2."
and they weren't going to cast
me in it, that's for sure.
So I was not sure
about showbusiness.
It seemed like a really
stupid idea for an Indian guy.
Also, you know, I had gotten
a lot of laughs in plays
that I had done in school, but
your friends laughing at you
is one thing.
But I decided I'd give
myself a test, which
was to find out if I could
make strangers laugh.
And so at Colgate,
juniors, a lot of them
go off to Europe or China
or somewhere and study.
I went and took a semester at
Loyola University in Chicago,
and I joined up with the
Improv Olympic, which is--
ALLAN WEINBERGER: Now iO.
JAY CHANDRASEKHAR: iO, right.
And I got into a beginning--
well, it was like
an improv class
taught by this guy
Del Close, who's
sort of the father of improv.
Chris Farley was in
that class at the time.
He was in the highest
group and his shows
with guys like Dave Koechner
and that were poetic.
I mean, they were amazing.
My shows, which were with
the beginning improvisers who
had just signed up,
were a grinding,
awful 45 minutes of silence.
I was not making strangers
laugh in this improv.
I mean, our group, it was awful.
And so I said, well, I'm
not passing my test here.
So I thought about--
I'm like, OK, I'm going to
write some stand-up jokes.
So I wrote 10 minutes
of stand-up jokes.
ALLAN WEINBERGER:
That's a lot of minutes.
JAY CHANDRASEKHAR: Yeah.
I mean, they said
you had to do 10.
So I signed up for an open mic.
And I went to a place called
the Match Stick, which
I think was in Lincoln Park.
And I went up on
a Tuesday night.
I drank like four Tom Collins,
which was inexplicably
my drink at the time.
I went into the awful
bathroom of that place
and had a nerve shit, frankly.
And then they called
my name, and I went up
and I did my 10 minutes of
stand-up in about five minutes.
I just raced through it.
I'm like, I got to
get off the stage.
But I got laughs.
Strangers were laughing.
And I'm like, OK, OK.
And so over the next
semester, I did--
another 20 times, I went up.
And sometimes I would kill,
and sometimes I would bomb,
and it was the same exact jokes.
And I found out that the more--
if I memorized every single
line, every breath, every look,
I would bomb.
Sometimes they'd be like,
OK, you're going up sixth,
and they'd call me up second.
And I'm like ah.
And they'd already called
you up, you're like, ah.
And you go up,
usually I would kill.
And I talked to my
mom, and she's like,
you know, you're telling
these jokes and they need to--
it should be like you're
in a bar telling jokes
to your friends.
It needs to feel spontaneous.
It's probably too canned
when you memorize.
I mean, it's one of those
few jobs where the more you
prepare, the worse you are.
ALLAN WEINBERGER:
I felt that way
with trying to pronounce
your name today.
I said it in the mirror
probably 100 times,
and the only time it
mattered, I fumbled.
JAY CHANDRASEKHAR:
Yeah, you botched it.
ALLAN WEINBERGER: Yeah, yeah.
JAY CHANDRASEKHAR:
You really botched it.
ALLAN WEINBERGER: I should've
just walked up and tried it.
JAY CHANDRASEKHAR: Yeah.
ALLAN WEINBERGER: So your
book "Mustache Shenanigans"--
which it is available here.
Google has subsidized the rate.
So if anyone would like them,
you can get them signed.
I think there's an
audiobook as well.
JAY CHANDRASEKHAR: Yeah.
ALLAN WEINBERGER: We don't
sell the audiobook here,
but you can get that online.
In the book, you talk a
lot about "Super Troopers"
and the making of it.
And one part that I
found really interesting
is that you actually
had access--
with the original script--
to a lot of these production
houses and Miramax.
And Harvey Weinstein
gave it a read,
and ultimately turned it down--
and a series of turndowns.
How did you guys
feel with this--
you know, you knew
you had something,
but it was getting
rejected all the time.
JAY CHANDRASEKHAR: Bad.
We made a film called
"Puddle Cruiser" first.
And we went to Sundance and
we had amazing screenings--
like packed houses, huge laughs.
People were like,
who are these guys?
And yet the film didn't sell.
And eventually it did sell, but
it didn't sell out of Sundance.
And we were like, now what?
So we wrote the script--
I mean, what happened was
Miramax flirted with buying it.
He flirted with buying it.
And Harvey just was
never in the room
when we had a big screening.
His staff is like, you
have to buy this movie.
And he goes, yeah,
set up a screening.
We'd set up a huge screening,
it'd get huge laughs,
he wouldn't show up.
And finally, he saw
it alone in his office
and he really liked it.
So he called me and he said,
this is a really good movie.
I want to make a
TV show out of it.
And I'm like, why don't
we just set up a screening
and you can watch it,
and you can buy it?
And he goes, OK, we'll
set up a screening.
So we set up a screening
and we did the screening
on 3rd Street and
11th Avenue, which
is right next to
NYU, where there
are a lot of film students.
And so we had this
big screening.
And, of course, Harvey
doesn't show up.
And the screening kills.
It's just great laughter.
His executives are like, it's
killing, you got to come.
So he comes and
arrives at the end
of the screening, which is
when the question and answer
with the audiences.
The audience is
loving the movie.
They're like, this
is a great movie.
It's about people
our age and da da da.
Then Harvey walks in, and one
by one these film students
look back and see the
king of independent film
and they all turn into
basically Pauline Kael.
And they're like, the framing
wasn't great on that one shot.
And they all start
trashing the movie.
They're like, we didn't
buy the characters.
And you're like, uh.
And he's like, sorry, kid.
He goes, but let's try
again on a new one.
And so he goes, bring me
the next script, I'll buy it
and we'll make that movie.
We wrote "Super Troopers."
And we wrote, like, 10
drafts of this thing,
and it got pretty damn good.
And his executives are like,
we're going to make this movie.
We gave it to Harvey.
He read it, and
he said, you know,
I don't know if it's funny.
And he goes, but don't feel
bad because I usually can't
tell when something's funny.
And I'm like, OK.
So he goes, but I'm
going to let you
have it back if you want to
go make it somewhere else.
He didn't have to do that.
He could have--
ALLAN WEINBERGER: They
can table it, right?
JAY CHANDRASEKHAR: Most
presidents of studios
just sit on it.
They're like, I'm
not going to make it,
but I don't want
someone else to make it
because then I'll look bad.
So they usually just sit on it
and just stick it in a vault.
But he let me have it
back because he liked me.
And then we went
around to everybody--
Warner Brothers,
Paramount, Universal.
They said, we'll make it.
They were going to make
it for $5.5 million,
but the producer then
couldn't work out his pay
and it was over.
It was out.
We were green lit,
and then we were not.
So then the Farrelly
brothers called.
They read it.
They said, this movie would
work if it was set in the '70s.
And we're like, OK.
So we wrote the
'70s version, and it
was called "Super Trooper '76."
Then Fox read it.
They're like, yeah,
it's good, but you guys
are going to star in it?
I don't think so.
And we're like, OK.
So then nobody would finance it.
Then we went to all the
independent financers
and we met with a
bunch of people.
One guy was like, I'll
give you the money
if Ben Affleck can play Thorny.
And I'm like, I'm
playing Thorny.
He goes, not in this
movie, you're not.
And I'm like--
So we really struck out.
Nobody would finance
the movie, basically
because we weren't stars.
Broken Lizard was basically
about to break up.
We packed up our office.
I was packing up my office and
I was going to move out to LA
and just try to audition
and see what happens.
And I was packing my
office and the phone rang,
and it was my friend Cricket
who I went to college with.
And she said, I hate to ask
you, but my dad's a banker,
and he's retiring and he
wants to write movie scripts.
And you're the only guy
who's sort of making movies,
so I told him about you and
he wants to talk to you.
And I said, OK, sure.
So I talked to him and he
goes, I wrote this script,
and it's like a girl
comedy road movie
and I'm wondering if
you could take a read.
And I'm like, yeah,
sure, I'll take a read.
And he goes, actually, before
I send it to you, why don't you
send me a sample of
your stuff so I just
know what your style is.
And I'm like, oh,
you're auditioning
me to read your script.
OK, got it.
So I sent him "Super
Troopers" and I'm like,
I hope he doesn't like
it because I don't
want to read his damn script.
And he calls me a week later.
And he's like, this
thing's pretty funny.
And I said, oh, yeah, thanks.
He goes, what's
going on with it?
And I'm like, well, nothing.
Nothing's going on with it.
We can't get any
money to make it.
And he goes, can you make
it for a million dollars?
And I said, yeah.
And he said, all right, I'll
give you a million dollars.
And I said, oh, OK.
And three weeks later we
were casting the movie.
And the movie sold for about
$3.25 million at Sundance.
I mean, he's made nine times
his investment on that movie.
Nobody in showbusiness
thought it was a good bet.
And this guy's like, OK,
and then there he goes.
ALLAN WEINBERGER:
So the movie went on
to make about $80 million--
well worth the investment there.
So "Super Troopers 2" is
coming out later this year.
Is that--
JAY CHANDRASEKHAR: In
the next six months.
ALLAN WEINBERGER: In
the next six months, OK.
And you guys did
something unique.
You went the route
of crowdfunding it.
Now, with such a
successful movie,
you'd think these movie houses
would be banging down your door
to get in on this action.
JAY CHANDRASEKHAR:
You would think.
ALLAN WEINBERGER: Fill me in.
Why'd you go the route
of crowdsourcing--
or crowdfunding?
JAY CHANDRASEKHAR: I mean,
the first film was a shock,
I think, to the studio, and
it continues to be a shock.
I mean, they listed it--
this was a number of years ago.
It was probably
five, six years--
maybe eight years ago.
They listed it on why Fox
had had such a good year.
It was "Star Wars,"
"Super Troopers."
I mean, this was like 10
years after it came out.
It was still just
churning money for them.
And so we were like, OK.
But there was so much
money made that we had--
and they, of course, were
like, oh, it didn't really
make that much.
And of course that's
the dance in Hollywood.
The studio's like,
oh, where's the money?
We don't know.
And then you audit them, and
then someone says, OK, this
is how much it really made.
You have to write them a check.
That's how it works.
And we all know it, and
we're all fine with it.
That's just what we do.
There was a debate--
there was an argument about
how much the profit was.
And so it was locked up
in a legal issue that
went on for four or five years.
And so it took a while.
And out of the settlement--
part of it was, OK,
you can make the movie.
But while that was happening,
the entire film business
became a business
that only wanted
to make movies where the main
characters were in tights
and wore capes.
That was the only kind of movie
they wanted to make at all.
And so when we went to ask them
to make it, they were like--
they said, look, we know
the sequel will make money,
we just don't know if
it'll make enough money.
And I'll give you an
example, a story here.
I had a deal at Warner Brothers.
And I went into the
president of Warner Brothers,
and he said, what kind of
movies are we going to make?
He goes, I want to make
$100 million comedies
with any of these two stars--
Johnny Depp, Ben Stiller,
Vince Vaughn, and Will Ferrell.
That's the whole list.
And I was like, OK, what
if instead we make five
$20-million movies and we'll
put some up-and-comers in it,
like Broken Lizard?
And you know, whatever, we'll
make some cheaper movies
and we'll be able
to make more of them
and we'll make
them more quickly.
And he goes, what's the most one
of those $20-million movies can
make?
And I said, $100 million.
That's a $80-million profit.
And he goes, that's a double.
He goes, we need
movies that will
gross $250 to $400 million.
We need grand slams.
We need movies that will
move the stock price.
And I was like--
ALLAN WEINBERGER: That sounds
like working at Google.
JAY CHANDRASEKHAR: Well,
that's the problem,
is that corporations
bought movie companies
because they wanted a
fun little media piece.
And then they saw
what "Iron Man" did
and they saw what these
really great superhero movies
are doing is making so much
money that the whole industry
has turned towards them only.
But to the exclusion of--
And I'll tell you,
the reason why
is because you
can take an action
film with a guy in tights and a
cape, and it can play in China,
it can play in India, it
can play all over the world.
The Chinese don't get
what meow versus--
they don't get it.
They're like, what?
What's funny about that?
And so the movies don't
travel well there,
and so there's a ceiling
on what comedies can make.
And as a result, they
don't to make them.
So it's the same with--
they don't make movies
like "Kramer vs. Kramer,"
like "Breaking Away,"
these smaller $20 to
$50-million movies.
They're like, no, no, put
them in a cape and the tights,
or we're out.
And so with "Super Troopers
2," I know they probably
had a conversation
where they're like,
do you think we could put
the "Super Troopers" in capes
and make them "Super" Troopers?
I mean, I'm sure they
had that conversation.
So they said, guys, go raise
the money and make the movie
and we'll release it.
Which, by the way, is a huge
gift to give us a release slot.
It's amazing.
So we did that.
And we decided to go to
a crowdfunding site--
Indiegogo-- and see if
we could raise money.
And the risk was if the audience
was like, nah, who cares,
we don't want to see a
sequel, it's been too long,
or whatever, then the
movie would have died
because the studio would
have been like, god,
nobody wants to see this.
But we raised $2 million in
24 hours and $4.7 million
over 30 days.
And after that, we were able
to raise a bunch more money
to make the film.
ALLAN WEINBERGER: So it's done?
It's ready to launch?
JAY CHANDRASEKHAR: It's done.
The editing is done.
We're now-- the Eagles of
Death Metal are my buddies
and they're recording
the soundtrack.
There's the score.
ALLAN WEINBERGER: Gotcha.
Well, in the book,
you go through a lot
of behind the scenes,
a lot of the anecdotes
from each part of the movie.
What we thought
would be a lot of fun
here is if we show
some clips of the movie
and you give us a little behind
the scenes what was going on,
what people can expect from the
book, and it'll be a lot of fun
here.
Following this, we'll
have a live Q&A.
So if anyone has any
questions, there'll
be a microphone over there.
But Nick, if you can
play the first clip.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- One, two, three, do it.
Aw, go girlfriend.
I'm your mother.
Come on, Thorny, you're
losing to the rookie.
It's embarrassing.
Come on, Rabbit, you can do it.
Oh, Rabbit, he's killing you.
I got Thorny in front by a lot.
What's the matter?
Your mama didn't
teach you how to chug?
Come on, Thorn.
Oh!
Oh.
[INAUDIBLE]
- I am all that is man.
- Every time.
- Finish it up.
See, there you have it.
You're doing it all wrong.
You got to open your
throat, relax the jaw.
- Don't forget to cup the balls.
You're never going to win
with those thin little bird
lips you got there.
See, this guy's got these
big old powerful lips.
Am I correct, Thorn?
- So much of my authority is
derived from the power right
here.
- Hey, guys.
[END PLAYBACK]
JAY CHANDRASEKHAR: That was
a real reaction, that "wow."
He was in trouble.
If you look at
that scene, there's
one shot in there where there's
a profile of us drinking,
and you can see that
the liquid in my bottle
is moving very quickly, because
that is very thick iced tea.
And so we shot that--
that was the master.
That was the wide.
And we shot that first.
And we looked at it, we're
like, it doesn't look right.
It looks like iced tea.
And so we sent a
production assistant out
to buy real maple syrup.
And he came back
with eight bottles.
I drank two full bottles.
I made Eric drink about three
bottles because I was like,
I don't think we have it yet.
You better go again, buddy.
And it was something
I will never do again.
I mean, after we did it
and we finished the scene,
we immediately went to the
bathroom to try to throw it up,
but it was too thick.
So then we went into--
It was lunch, and we
went into my trailer
because we were
not feeling good.
And we turned the light out
and we lay on the ground
and just shivered
for about 45 minutes.
And I really
thought I might die.
You're like, I might die.
He had the rest of the day off.
I had to shoot a love
scene, which didn't even
make into the movie.
And then afterwards I went--
we were staying in a
motel near Poughkeepsie,
and I went back to the motel.
I went to his room.
And he came out of his room and
he goes, have you pooped yet?
ALLAN WEINBERGER: Oh, no.
JAY CHANDRASEKHAR: And I said,
no, but I'm headed there now.
And he goes, there's
a reason maple syrup
is part of the Master Cleanse.
And I'll spare you
the gory details,
but things came out of me that
I don't remember ever going in.
Like, I shat a
fossilized bird, like,
a stick with a fully
intact leaf on it.
I was like, oh, OK, I
don't remember that.
But it's not good.
Never again.
ALLAN WEINBERGER:
All right, we don't
need to bring the maple
syrup out that I had planned.
Let's play the second clip.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Sorry about that.
- All right, meow, hand over
your license and registration.
Your registration.
- Oh.
- Hurry up meow.
- Sorry.
- Is there something
funny here, boy?
No.
No, no.
- Well, then why are you
laughing, Mr. Larry Johnson?
All right, meow, where were we?
- I'm sorry, are
you saying meow?
- Am I saying meow?
- I thought--
- Don't think, boy.
Meow, do you know how
fast you were going?
Meow, what is so damn funny?
- I could've swore
you said meow.
- Do I look like
a cat to you, boy?
Am I jumping around all
nimbly-bimbly from tree
to tree?
- No, no.
- Am I drinking
milk from a saucer?
- No.
- Well, do you see
me eating mice?
Now you stop laughing right now.
- Yes, sir.
- Meow, I'm going to have to
give you a ticket on this one.
- But--
- No buts meow.
That's the law.
Not so funny meow, is it?
Meow!
[END PLAYBACK]
JAY CHANDRASEKHAR: That scene--
we were writing "Super
Troopers" and we were in--
the five of us were sleeping
in a motel in Burbank
because we didn't
have much cash.
And we were up
smoking and joking
and it was about
4:30 in the morning.
And I have a bad left ear from
like ear infections as a kid
from--
I used to swim in this lake
that was kind of dirty.
And so the ear's not that great.
And I heard somebody say
something now and I say,
did you say meow?
And then for the next hour
we riffed on sentences
with meow replacing now.
And then we just went to bed.
And somebody wrote on a
napkin now equals meow.
And three weeks later, we
were in a writing meeting
and someone's like-- we were
trying to think of a pullover.
What could you do?
And someone's like,
remember that thing
we did where the
meow is the now?
And we're like, oh, yeah.
And so we wrote up
that little scene.
And we were reading it.
Once we finished the
movie, we were reading it.
And at one point I was
going to be the meow guy.
I was going to be in that scene.
But the movie takes
place in Vermont.
And you're like, OK.
The problem with the
scene was we read it
without a Southern accent
and it wasn't that funny.
It just didn't land.
And then when we put a
Southern accent on it,
it was really funny.
And I'm like, I said I could buy
a white Southerner in Vermont,
I could buy that.
But like an Indian guy with
a southern accent in Vermont,
I was like, I just don't buy it.
So I had Paul do it,
and, you know, lucky him.
ALLAN WEINBERGER:
So a lot of times
these, jokes, they just
take off on their own.
I went to see Dave Chapelle
once and someone yelled out,
I'm Rick James, bitch, and I
could see him die a little.
Do you ever get approached
and yelled like, meow,
or, can I go on a mustache ride?
JAY CHANDRASEKHAR:
Every 10 minutes.
And because of my left
ear, I often miss it.
But, yeah, people come
up to me and they slip it
in all the time.
And usually I really do miss it.
And then I'm like, I got it.
I got it.
And the mustache rides--
yeah, yeah, a lot of women
ask me to give them
mustache rides.
[INAUDIBLE]
ALLAN WEINBERGER: I've never
had that happen yet, but--
JAY CHANDRASEKHAR: You've
never had that happen?
ALLAN WEINBERGER: Not once.
Not once.
Let's play the third clip.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
JAY CHANDRASEKHAR: Oh, yeah.
- Welcome to Dimpus.
Can I take your order?
- Give me a double
bacon cheeseburger.
- Double baco cheeseburger.
It's for a cop.
- What the hell
is that all about?
He going to spit in it now?
- No, I was just telling him
that so he makes it good.
Don't spit in that cop's burger.
- Yeah, thanks.
- Roger.
[INAUDIBLE]
- Give me a pie.
Apple.
- Do you want me
to hold the spit?
Just kidding, Officer Farva.
So do you want to dimpusize
your meal for a quarter more?
FARVA: You want me to
punchicize your face for free?
- Some male figure?
I'm his dad.
And stop with the
whole transfer thing.
- [INAUDIBLE]
- You know what?
I got to go.
Let's talk about this later, OK?
OK, bye.
- Now, don't give me any lip.
- It's just a quarter.
And look how much more you get.
- I said, no.
- It's just $0.25.
- Hey, listen, guy,
he doesn't want it.
- I can handle this, Rama Thorn.
I don't want it.
- Right.
Beverage?
- Give me a liter of cola.
- A what?
- A liter of cola.
- Liter of cola.
Do we make liter of cola?
- Will you just
order a large, Farva?
- I don't want a "Large Farva."
I want a goddamn liter of cola.
- I don't know what that is.
- Liter is French for give
me some fucking cola before I
break those fucking lips!
- All right, all right, relax!
[END PLAYBACK]
JAY CHANDRASEKHAR: I have a
lot to say about that scene.
The kid who played the
Dimpus Burger Guy is a guy
named Charlie Finn.
And I discovered him on
the streets of Hollywood.
I went to the Improv
Olympic in Hollywood
looking for guys that age to put
into a pilot we were shooting.
And I didn't really see
anybody perform that day.
But then I went outside
and I saw this guy
smoking a cigarette, and
he's like meh, meh, meh.
He was just talking real funny.
And I went up to him, and I
was like, are you an actor?
And he goes, I guess.
And I was like, you want to
audition for an NBC pilot?
He goes, OK.
And he'd never been
on an audition.
He was just a funny guy
who moved out to Hollywood.
He was in the Improv Olympic.
And we got him onto this NBC
show and he was hilarious.
And so we cast him in this role.
And it's probably my favorite
performance in the movie.
I love this guy.
So the origin of
this scene was--
we used to go to
Burger King in our--
Let me go back.
Let me talk about
something else.
So McDonald's invented
the notion of supersizing.
I think it was while
we were in college.
They used to have just
small, medium, large.
Then they invented
the supersized.
And their employees
were instructed
to badger the customers
until they upsold this thing.
And so you'd go in, you're
like, I'll have a large.
They're like, you
want to supersize it
for a quarter more?
And I'm like, no.
They're like, it's
just a quarter.
I'm like, no.
They're like, it's
just a quarter.
I mean, really, just a quarter?
And I became so
frustrated by it that we
wrote that scene into that.
And then the liter--
the Burger King in
our town was managed
by a guy who I'm certain
was a Canadian because he
had small, medium, and liter.
He did not have a large.
And we would roll in, hungover
on a Saturday afternoon,
and buy liters of iced tea.
But I'm an American.
I want a large iced tea.
I do not want a liter.
I do not go metric.
And so we'd go in and we'd say--
I'd say, give me a large
iced tea or a large Coke.
And he instructed his workers
to say, we don't have larges,
we only have liters.
And so I'd sit there at
the speaker and be like,
give me a large.
And he's like, we don't
have large, just a liter.
And we would go at it.
And finally I'm like,
fine, give me a liter.
And this Canadian
bastard just won this--
he won.
He won.
And we got him back.
ALLAN WEINBERGER: All right.
Thank you very much for that.
We're going to
open it up to Q&A.
So if anyone has
any questions, there
is a microphone over there.
Not all at once, guys.
AUDIENCE: Hey, there.
So first off, go 'Gate.
So fellow Colgate alum.
And I've always
wondered this and been
asked this a lot-- because
coming from Chicago,
people used to ask
why you would end up
in Upstate New York to me.
And I'm wondering,
for you-- who I
would assume at the
time you probably
had a sense of the dramatic
arts is where you wanted to go--
and obviously New York and
NYU or Northwestern or USC
might have seemed like more
logical solutions for that.
How did you end up at
a small liberal arts
school in Upstate New
York versus a more
traditional dramatic program?
JAY CHANDRASEKHAR: How
I ended up at Colgate,
which ended up
shaping my whole life,
is one of the great
flukes in my story.
Colgate, for those of
you that don't know,
it's got 2,750 students.
It's 3 and 1/2 hours
north of New York City.
It's a beautiful--
it's a great school.
It's like number
19 in the country.
And it's surrounded
by farmland basically,
but it's a beautiful place.
It wins the most beautiful
campus in the country
almost every year.
And so I, in high school, had
a very high opinion of myself.
I really-- while I didn't have
the grades to get into the Ivy
League, I thought, they're
going to let me in anyway.
And so I applied to Harvard,
Yale, Stanford, Dartmouth,
I applied to Northwestern,
and Brown, and that's it.
And I was like, yeah and my
grade point average was B-plus.
And I'm like, OK, but they're
going to love my personality
and they're going to love my--
I'm going to get in.
And so I started to second-guess
myself late in January.
I'm like, I'm a little worried.
What happens if I
don't get in anywhere?
And I'm walking down
the hallway and I
happen to run into my
girlfriend at the time.
And I said, you know, I'm a
little nervous about where
I applied to schools.
I said, do you have any
applications in your locker?
And she goes,
yeah, I think I do.
And so we go to her
locker and she pulls out
one for Boston College, Boston
University, and Colgate.
And I look at them,
and I'm like, OK,
my essay can fit these.
So I ran around to my teachers.
I'm like, you got to
send it out today.
They send out recommendations.
The three schools
that I got into
were Boston College, Boston
University, and Colgate.
And with all of
the A-plus Indians
that these schools
had to sift through,
they certainly didn't want
this junky old B-plus Indian.
I mean, they're like, why would
we take you, B-plus Indian?
And so I looked at
the rankings and I'm
like, OK, Colgate's higher than
these other two, I'll go there.
And so that's why
I went to Colgate.
And it's the greatest
place on earth.
I mean, I loved that
place more than--
I only cry about once a decade.
I don't know.
I have very dry tear ducts.
And I wept at the
bar on the last night
when I had to leave
there because I loved it.
It's still my favorite place.
AUDIENCE: Can I ask which bar?
JAY CHANDRASEKHAR: The Jug.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, there we go.
JAY CHANDRASEKHAR: There
are two bars in town--
The Jug and The [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: I was like, it's
that or The [? Bacon, ?] yeah.
JAY CHANDRASEKHAR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hey there.
I'm curious what
kind of response
you got from patrolmen and
women and the police community.
Did they like it?
Did you capture it?
Were they offended?
What were some of
the best responses?
JAY CHANDRASEKHAR: We thought
we would be frequently arrested
after we made that film.
And it was sort of-- we didn't
really hear about anything much
until we made "Beerfest."
And we were down in Albuquerque
and we were making "Beerfest."
And to try to get in
character, we basically
had a beer pong
party every night.
We were playing a lot of
beer pong, and we were loud.
So we had these huge parties.
And on like a Tuesday night,
there was a noise complaint.
And there was a
knock on the door.
I open the door,
and it's two cops.
And I was like--
look, I've always been
very polite to cops.
And so I'm like,
hey, guys, so sorry.
My apologies.
And the cop looks at me and
then he looks at his partner
and he goes, you have
a good evening, sir.
And they turn around
and walk away.
And I'm like, OK.
And so I close the door and
I'm like, I don't know what--
they didn't say anything.
I said, they just left.
And I'm like, OK.
10 minutes later, I open the
door again, another knock, it's
seven cops.
And the same guy
goes, can we come in
and party with you, sir?
And I was like, yeah.
And I'm leading the pack,
I'm like, hide the bongs.
And they stayed for
like a half an hour.
And we just drank and
raged and had a great time.
And it was then that I realized
that what they like about this
movie is that they're--
mostly in Hollywood, we have
crooked cops and evil cops
or really good cops who
are just super nice.
We made human cops,
I think, to them.
They feel human in our
film and they feel like--
they are bored sometimes, they
do mess around with people
sometimes.
I mean, it has become
hard to get a ticket.
We speed, they pull us over,
they walk up, they're like,
oh, I'm sorry, sir.
Are you in a hurry?
Do you need an escort somewhere?
Kevin Heffernan,
he played Farva.
We were throwing out the first
pitch in San Diego Qualcomm
Stadium and he was late.
So he was driving 90 down
the 405, gets pulled over.
The cop says, oh my god, Farva!
And he goes, I'm throwing
out the first pitch.
He goes, follow me.
They drive 105 down
to the stadium.
Kevin doesn't know
where to park.
The cop's like, just
stick it right there.
And he gets out, and each
cop is like, I got him.
And they're walking him
all the way into the mound.
It's amazing, right?
It's amazing.
AUDIENCE: That's fantastic.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I was wondering if
there are any actual plans
to release "Potfest," or
was that just a fun trailer
with Willie Nelson?
JAY CHANDRASEKHAR: They don't
have a drug testing policy
here?
Because test this guy.
AUDIENCE: We actually don't
have a very strict drug testing
policy.
JAY CHANDRASEKHAR:
Well, at the end
of "Beerfest," there's
a joke about "Potfest,"
which was a real joke.
I mean, we were really kidding.
But then there
are so many people
who keep asking us
about making "Potfest."
And then I've got to know a
lot of the famous stoners.
I've gotten to know--
Willie, of course,
wants to do it.
I met Snoop.
He wants to do it.
Cheech and Chong
both want to do it.
Doug Benson wants to do it.
We've written about
40 or 50 pages of it,
but then we just get high
and lose our [INAUDIBLE].
If we can ever focus and
get it done, we'll do it.
We'll do it.
AUDIENCE: So I thought
it was really interesting
how you talked about Hollywood
wanting to do superhero movies.
And I think those tend
to lend themselves
to sequels that are all right.
And I'm a huge
"Super Troopers" fan.
Have you got a lot of flak
about that-- of like, all right,
we're going to do
a sequel and I hope
it doesn't ruin the first
one or anything like that?
JAY CHANDRASEKHAR:
Yeah, from ourselves,
because we have
the same feelings
you do about certain sequels.
We're like, should
we risk ruining it?
Yeah, we will.
But ultimately what
we decided was--
I told everybody--
it's been a while,
so I said I'll only shoot
the movie if we're exactly
the same weight.
So people will be able
to say, you look older,
but you don't look
fatter and older.
I didn't want people to be able
to say you look fatter, too.
So everybody got down to weight.
And I also thought, let's
make the mustaches bigger.
That'll help, too.
So my mustache is
like twice the size.
Ultimately, we really wanted
to just make another one.
"NYPD Blue" made 200 episodes.
We can make two of these
damn things, right?
I feel like the key is just
to keep the tone the same.
And I know that tone.
I rewatched the movie
before I shot it.
And I'm like, OK, tough,
funny, try to make it smart,
make all the jokes make
sense, and keep all the jokes
within a certain bandwidth.
Everything has to feel
like it's possible.
Everything has to
feel like it's real.
And cast good actors who
know their way around a joke.
And I was worried about it.
But I mean, we've now shown
it to about 500 people
in California at three or
four 200-person screenings,
and the response has
been incredibly good.
So is it better than this one?
Probably not.
I mean, I think this movie
caught a certain wave that you
can't necessarily recreate.
But it has a ton of jokes in it.
We wrote 30 drafts.
We really worked hard on it.
And I think you'll be able to
play the movies back to back
and be like, yeah,
they're both good.
AUDIENCE: That's awesome.
And did you get pushed for any
cameos, speaking of casting
and things like that?
Or were people desperate
to get their hands on it?
JAY CHANDRASEKHAR: Yeah.
I mean, I was making a TV
show with Rob Lowe called
"The Grinder" and we
got along really well.
He's a really funny guy.
He's like a comic trapped
in a leading man's body.
He's just a funny, funny guy.
And so I shot,
like, four of those.
And then the last one,
we were in his trailer--
whatever, he smokes cigars.
And I got a part for him.
And I just said, hey,
any chance you'd consider
being in "Super Troopers."
He goes, I'm in.
I don't even have to
read the script, I'm in.
And I was like, OK, great.
Everybody we asked said yes.
And so we've got some
fun people in it--
people that fit
the roles, though.
We don't just stick famous
people in movies because--
The reason that movie is what it
is is because we picked a tone
and we stuck to the tone.
We don't just put any joke in.
It has to fit the tone.
And the second
movie is the same.
Every actor fits a tone,
every joke fits a tone.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ALLAN WEINBERGER: So
Jay, thank you very
much for coming in to Google.
We really appreciate
you coming here.
For everyone else, the
book is available outside--
"Mustache Shenanigans."
And he'll be sticking
around to take some photos
and some autographs.
Thanks again, Jay.
JAY CHANDRASEKHAR: Thanks.
ALLAN WEINBERGER:
Appreciate the time.
JAY CHANDRASEKHAR:
Appreciate it.
[APPLAUSE]